[Música]
meu adversário não isso não é
aires onde um pulmão e aí galera que
assistiu o planalto para vocês eu estou
aqui só para entrevistar uma pessoa ela
mesma a minha saúde mental
ai meu deus que seu claro antes de
começar a ouvir eu queria pedir a você
que está assistindo o vídeo agora clique
em gostei para o vídeo não esqueça se
você não curte o vídeo se você no clipe
gostei deixa de enviar o vídeo você não
recebe mais um vídeo há três semanas não
sabe que esteve de novo então clica que
gostei que isso ajuda demais você sempre
recebeu o vídeo novo a paz e fará um
show em luziânia eu tô gravando esse
vídeo hoje que a gravação do dvd no rio
de janeiro agora dia 23 pela ligação do
neto de poder saber como é que vai ser
oi e aí eu estou fazendo show em
luziânia hoje time do interior não
escuta não tá aonde tem que me ligar
é preciso saber mais para poder saber
como é que vê lá porque está dando certo
para a i liga pelo google duas equipas
na liga pelo google que dignifica ética
bom isso aqui não funciona não é melhor
do mundo pelo google dá para se ver a
qualidade é top demais pai eu tô aqui
luziânia agora aqui sim eu era a
qualidade de vida top + mundo o legal
foi dia 2 o dvd e para nós também para a
pré-estreia do filme é não acham
mas aí tu vai poder vender para chegar
de um ou no dia 6 2 que dia 2 o dvd
falou oi é bom para conversar ainda
começando a estréia do filme os passos
que eu toco no tirulipa aí o bruno de
luca e tom cavalcante que é dia 30 de
novembro agora vá ao cinema assistir o
filme a comédia sensacional muito
engraçada e no dia 2 de dezembro tem o
meu dvd uma tv de que não vem falar em
especial meu solo lá no rio
no genesis arena às 20 horas quem quiser
comprar seu ingresso é nesse site
primeiro na descrição do vídeo e esse
aplicativo que acabei de falar com o
neto se chama google do que se fala com
a qualidade top de vídeo esse é o
diferencial dele e eu vou tá aprendendo
algumas pessoas nesse número que tá pode
baixar o google duas no seu celular
a agenda é esse número aqui você pode
ligar pelo google do que eu vou
aprendendo as pessoas em vídeo e algum
dia da semana e se pode baixar a agendar
esse número fica tentando nesse número
aqui google do pode ligar para você já
aproveitam esse problema ia faltar no
interior da avó dele eu sou menino
interior eu nasci e fui criado interior
agora mora na capital mas eu sei que tem
muita diferença entre a capital eo
interior não será do interior tem nada a
ver com o capital é tudo diferente tutu
diferente em oito diferentes da capital
mas cidade do interior são tudo igual
você mora no interior se vai demitir
agora que tem isso aqui na sociedade o
interior de um bar chamado esquina barra
ba se pode passar a qualquer momento
qualquer horário do dia qualquer feriado
qual que vai ter um bebê sentado taha
percebo é famoso e conhecido da cidade é
imortal que quando seu bisavô era
pequeno tinha medo desse bbb já foi
usado em educar você ou algum prêmio
right to party no chão lá na capital tem
o que tem barzinhos o jogo para o brasil
com os amigos ou não esse vídeo é tese
nem naquele barzinho a área das crianças
em cada linha que faz assim de xbox para
os meninos brincarem jack banco tem um
chão a coisa me parece crise não esse
carinho quem tem um mês que na bateria
final mas golfe que vai com o pai é o
pai com uma cachaça e me roubando
ensinou que é assim que vai por mim para
encher o saco não morrer no meio da rua
teófilo a jogar sinuca chama o menino eo
joga sinuca ainda que a bp está
conversando com o amigo vacilou na não
eu plantei os caminho acho nenhum eu
pensei que esse ano não foi nada a
plantação quando passei para a terra
o menino faz isso assim convencer rafa
vai até amanhã e jipovura fukushima 1 1
ela me abandonou papai inscritos em toda
cidade que quer ter uma panificadora
ideal a panificadora da cidade na
capital não captam tenho feito ele
leandro finkler ontem vários capital tem
um lugar desses aí tem podem mil praça
lugar para o reino é autor de ciclismo
em gaeta mil landic dankley de seikan
sendo inter eu não tenho só tem um ponto
de encontro que a praça praça da igreja
que é a praça que tem na frente da
igreja cada pessoa quer ver fulana
partido verde está na praça igreja você
vai na praça a igreja se fulano estiver
lá pode chamar a polícia que a cotação
do crude é o primeiro beijo das pessoas
atrás da igreja primeira vez e beija
menina que era a primeira vez que a
banda beijo miniatura de gramsci deus
abençoasse todos os primeiros beijos que
foi atrás da igreja a gente teria menos
de volta a chover o animal que tem em
todo lugar tem na capital e também no
interior também maior diferença é a
criação de capital caiu de capital um
cachorro que mora em apartamento neve no
sofá
a vida tem dois filhotes como é que sabe
que vai ter dois filhotes o transition
que a gente levou a a belinha lá no
veterinário de diferença 113 sul tem
dois vigilantes uma coisa livre onde
chega na casa do amigo meu em são paulo
o cachorro foi passar a mão na cabeça o
não do barcelona é linha dura não porque
ela fez uma cesárea é meu deus do céu no
interior não tem isso cachorro no
interior o dono tem que entender o
seguinte às vezes ele tem o cachorro às
vezes não tem achou do interior ela some
grávida ela volta com 18 filhotes atrás
ninguém sabe o que fazer com o cachorro
apartamento ele a da estrada porque o
adestrador vem aqui fazendo fazer um
nicho aprendi que achou do interior só
tem um adestrador que é o dono do
cachorro vai me já nunca mais de casa
o mais diferente que eu acho que tem da
capital o interior é o futebol na
capital - joga no futebol soçaite hoje
vou levar o trt para jogar no futebol
sad que do lar nem colete para poder
botar pra diferenciar qualquer tim em
tempo dez minutos viram e desde luta é
carmen melhorar para jogar cara joga
toda terça 20 horas 8 horas da noite
novo 20 horas 20 anos joga no interior
não têm horário não meus caros e tá
dormindo do nada alguém abra a porta de
seu quarto que é um ator do advogado já
não tem um menino família chico pedro
taque de bofe doni para isso foi notado
na volta tudo só vai ganhar um título
pessoal da casa que espera espera pode
montar você pode estar morto jeito que
você vai ao cabo foi a total foi a maior
banca para levantar para encarar o time
chega lá e aí quem sabe a bola domingo
vágner love que vocês que joga sem bola
não tem que ter pegado no retalho e
montei para instalar e tem que chegar em
primeiro para demarcar o campo com pepe
no lugar e no interior do tempo você
saber se a bola saiu não tão alguém
chega primeiro a fazer a linha cada
pessoa está fazendo aquilo tudo
quadradinho toró do interior é o
primeiro e único jogo do mundo dentro de
um triângulo e fica tudo assim a área
para sua pirâmide a trave é do sul
quênia é um pau assim um negócio aqui
o paok com o negócio aqui irmão pau em
cima assim o papa disse não fica só
encaixado eu fico eu sou toda vez que
alguém chuta a bola bate na trave pouco
em cima da cabeça o golo e não perdi o
futebol sandy shen da rede bola não sair
né cara chuta pra qualquer lugar bate na
rede cai dentro
no interior a rede é o menino ou menina
é doido por bola fica história na bola e
falou ele buscar o cara chuta bolso
[Aplausos]
o menino corre para buscar todo menino
do interior faz essa pose apoia numa
perna só para descansar ou outra eu acho
que ele fica muito sem saber o que é que
faz com esse braço aqui então ele segura
o outro
acho que tem medo que alguém roube esse
braço por isso ele segura com esse e
gera emprego que todo jogo de futebol
desse jeito de interior domingo que vem
dia 19 e até hoje não foi pega em um
centavo um tempo cada lata de coco tem
de coco queimar tem de biscoito conhece
kaká é um e 25 é tirá lo do que o
senador é um homem fica te dá quatro
real a 4 rap moço não vamos ninguém aqui
mãe na briga
eu somente fogo 25 4 na china interior
cara mas é isso aí eu tenho saudade do
interior se você tiver gostado esse
vídeo não esqueça de clicar em gostei
aqui no youtube está o botão que ali
embaixo lindo gostei do que você comente
aqui embaixo que você acha mais
engraçado interessante nesses interiores
da vida aí nesses nessa cidade e das o
voto na sua própria cidade se você mora
no interior o que você acha mais
interessante comenta aqui embaixo e
principalmente está no facebook cut se
você já foi no interior desse jeito está
grande curte a foto você assistiu veio
pelo instagram e as redes sociais são
essas é na equipe